Das ist wirklich eine schlechte nachricht der status james webb weltraumteleskop
wird schon wieder verschoben und der grund ist diesmal ziemlich beunruhigen das revolutionäre teleskop
funktioniert nicht richtig was konkret schiefgelaufen ist und welche konsequenzen es hat jetzt in klicks zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich eine sehr schlechte nachricht der staates absolut
revolutionären james webb weltraumteleskop es muss schon wieder verschoben werden das teleskop wird eine neue stufe der forscher erreichen
wenn es denn endlich gestartet ist das riesen weltraumteleskop hat eine achtung
hundertfach bessere auflösung als das derzeitige
rekord weltraumteleskop hubble das ist wirklich spektakulär das james webb weltraumteleskop
kurz cabrio s t ist nämlich speziell darauf vorbereitet leben auf exoplaneten zu entdecken anhand des sternenlichts dass
durch die atmosphäre
eines solchen planeten zu uns gelangt kann diese atmosphäre analysiert werden und das cabrio es kann das mit ungeahnter
perfektion und zog zudem im infraroten bereich dieser
langweilige bereich dringend besser aus allen teilen des weltraums zu uns durch gibt es auf den vom
bdst untersuchten planeten leben hat die atmosphäre
eine ganz bestimmte zusammensetzung und diese kann dann anhand der bilder perfekt analysiert
werden es ist also ein riesen schritt bei der suche nach
außerirdischem leben zudem soll es in die zeit kurz nach dem urknall blicken und die struktur und entwicklung von galaxien untersuchen hier könnten
bedeutende erkenntnisse zur dunklen materie und deren existenz oder eben auch nicht
existenz gewonnen werden und sterne und planetensysteme
sollen näher beobachtet werden durch die wirklich
ungeheuerliche auflösung sind von dem teleskop wirklich unglaubliche erkenntnisse und aufnahmen zu erwarten doch jetzt kann man sagen
wann das sein wird das steht in den sternen nein ganz so ist es nicht aber das ist schon ein rückschlag bei einem stresstest
lockerten sich jetzt einige schrauben und das land darf natürlich nicht sein
jetzt muss geklärt werden woran es lag und das problem beseitigt werden damit dafür genug zeit bleibt wurde der staat jetzt vom mai
2020 auf den dreißigsten märz
2021 verschoben dieses datum und das ist die gute nachrichten soll jetzt verbindlich sein wir sind gespannt wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte am boxi auf youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir auch noch vor allen von neuesten video
täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der schutzschirm media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken alien suche heute beginnt eine neue ära bis dahin
bleibt dran